do you think you might be a little
self-destructive
oh yeah definitely self-destructive
yeah without even thinking about it
i don't even think about it till after i
i've destructed myself
all right dakota dakota oh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
originally i'm from chester west
virginia um i moved to pittsburgh but uh
originally from west virginia west
virginia and tell me about your
your family growing up you had both your
parents um
i didn't have the most ideal childhood
you know i had um
two biological parents they uh i had
eight kids
um i you know they lost all of us on and
off growing up we were all in and out of
foster care
and uh i have a i had a little brother
his name was isaiah
he died when he was 38 days old you know
unknown death so why did you guys end up
in foster care um
just you know our parents would end up
in jail or you know
get get arrested again you know and then
go back to the state you know because
the family members were tired of taking
eight kids in you know what i'm saying
right so uh yeah we were just in and out
of that
you know system for a while
and how would you describe your
childhood um
it was unique but it wasn't normal you
know it was uh
unstable you know i'd say but uh
it was uh it was rough yeah you get
through high school
um you know through high school it
it see i ended up getting adopted later
like in this childhood
so um the people who adopted us they
were good good people and and
the life was was good after that but um
like i said just start the start was
rough did you finish high school
i did i did finish high school and after
school would you where'd you go after
that
well i started working on dead-end
construction jobs
you know usually with a bunch of drug
addicts
that uh lots of drugs in west virginia
tons
tons you know which uh which
you know i went right down that road
that they did you know the older guys
doing the drugs so
i kind of set myself up for failure
there
and how do you know 22 22.
and you came to l.a how long ago
um october 27 2020 20. our 22 27 uh
seven about seven months ago roughly
what what made you come to l.a well
i was uh kind of committing insurance
fraud i was getting paid to go to rehabs
and they were just kicking us in and out
of these facilities
you know and paying us and then billing
the insurance companies
puku bucks and breaking us off pennies
you know so
that's how i ended up out here and uh
that all came to a halt when i got put
on a blacklist
for uh going to too many of them
and that left you homeless yeah left me
homeless and uh
stranded in l.a so where do you where do
you stay now you're gonna attend i stay
here i'm just getting around to tent
yeah
on uh fifth in um san pedro right
what do you think of skid row
that's crazy it's wow you know you got
i don't know what they're putting in the
food or the drugs or whatever it is but
you know you see all these people
talking to themselves and dancing in the
mornings and
you know thinking they're like
performing a concert for nobody but
their sales i mean i like i watch them
sometimes and i
i don't like to see that i'm watching
because when they know that they got a
little audience they turn it up ten you
know so
i just you know just peek over and
waiting at like the missions for
breakfast
or whatever i just like kind of watch
them and uh thinking like
are these people this [ __ ] crazy or
are they playing this crazy
that's what i ask myself but i can't
tell
i don't know who can there's a million
flavors of crazy down here too oh
yeah so are drugs a part of your life
yeah yeah
what's your drug now um i i mainly have
stuck with uh opiates you know my whole
life so um i progressed from you know
pain pills to heroin
and now fentanyl you know but east coast
drugs are a lot different than you know
west coast drugs it's a lot more
intensified out here
a lot more i'd say uh deadly and potent
you know so so uh the painkillers are a
big thing in west virginia right
oh yeah yeah they were just
phenomenal the amount of you know
prescriptions getting pushed out of that
state
yeah yeah and how do you support
yourself now
um to be honest i uh like to recycle
um i was
selling a lot of drugs you know which i
ended up getting a severe injury over so
i uh
cut that off tell me about your your
injury what happened to you
um well i kind of seen this place that i
originally started buying
drugs from and i knew the hours that
they were working
so i uh you know had a business man mine
and i said well
while these guys aren't here i'm just
gonna post up down the street a little
bit and
sell their [ __ ] that i'm behind you know
and uh word got out that i was down
there making a little money you know
when they weren't there so uh
that i'm not gonna say any names but the
main guy had put one of his workers to
come buy something off me
and the hours that i was there and he
the guy did and i
obviously gave it to him and uh he
seemed that it was his stuff just
chopped up a little bit
added a little bit of you know impurity
to it
and uh i wasn't happy with it so
my stupid ass shows back up to just keep
doing the same routine
and um i see some guys pull up and pull
a gun out
you know and i just took off running and
i got shot in my shoulder
you know about 38 i still have a bull
and bullet in my bone i never went to
the hospital or nothing because
you know i was told that they will
contact the state police immediately and
i got warrants you know in
multiple states oh so you don't go to
the hospital because you have warrants
yeah yeah
so what's it like being shot by a 38
um it's no fun you know but
but kind of how it happened was when
luckily i seen the tip
at the table the gun was silver so i
knew what it was when i seen it and i
took off running
you know and they kind of even drove up
like it's like kind of smart actually
saying like hey you got anything for
sale
and i've seen it was like a really nice
car and stuff something like this didn't
feel right and then when i seen that i i
took off sprinting down this hill
and uh you know when they did shoot me i
think that they thought they had got me
in the head or the heart or whatever
because
whenever the bullet had hit me i went
like cartwheeling almost
through the air you know i cracked my
skull open here and
here you know kind of remind myself of
like a deer
running through a field that someone
just shot you know and they had peeled
off and just took off
the power of the bullet it just yeah it
took me off my feet
running downhill you know and kind of
lifted me up and just
i started rolling you know and i got up
and just still continued running until i
just i felt like a bunch of sweat you
know pouring down and i looked down it's
just
blood running off my fingers and [ __ ]
was this
you know i just stopped right where i
was that was kind of like on the side of
a freeway
i got a blanket wrapped around my arm
and my shoulder because i heard cop
sirens like two minutes
later you know i didn't want to stop and
ask see how this blood you know
i got what happened you know but the
cops uh
they actually passed me out so i was
walking after this happened
you know and i hit the blood pretty good
and i've seen them all
with our lights on now i knew they were
coming after someone just called the
police about gunshots
you know i'm thinking like a smart
average person be like waving them down
like call paramedic or something but
i was i had drugs on me too so i mean
yeah
where am i yeah drug deal going bad
[ __ ]
don't believe him you know that's what
the price is what i was thinking it was
going to happen so
and you feel like your life's still in
danger now ah
well see i um i'm connected with a
couple other people that i talked to
about it
and uh they had went and talked to them
and kind of settled on agreement like uh
you know he's a young kid and he really
didn't know the rules out here
which kind of i kind of did but i act
like i didn't
and they kind of like and the guys
respected me for not
telling police anything so that's how it
works down here nobody goes
you know let bygones go by guns no more
uh trespassing
what i call it yeah that's morning shot
yeah
so do you have contact with your family
back home
oh yeah yeah i'm not as much as they'd
like
you know i call them like once a week
you know and uh
yeah they they try and uh you know shoot
me a little bit of money here and there
help me out financially but they don't
uh
they they're not dumb they know what i'm
doing they know what i what i
did you know drugs i wouldn't spot you
as a
drug addict an opiate addict right off
the bat no
you look pretty straight no last year
around this time
i weighed uh 226 pounds
163 pounds right now if you would have
seen me then and now
you you spot me out pretty quick yeah
yeah i lost a lot of weight and it's not
that i'm not eating good out here
because you know they
[ __ ] feed us some starbucks what is
it
is it the um it's just
i'd say it's opiates you know and uh
as much as i can you know i don't like
to sleep a lot because
you go to sleep too long you wake up but
some of the drugs out here you'll stay
up all night
oh yeah the crystal meth is i don't i
don't even like
i do touch it but i don't like to
because yeah like i said
if i just so i slept last night but you
know prior to that i was up for like
three days straight you know trying to
sleep right just didn't happen
yeah so you're still a young man what do
you see for your future
yeah yeah i don't see la as a
my future lifestyle forever because
i i talk to some of these guys that you
know they they like
talk like say it as like it's like a
badge of honor like i've been on
skateboard for 30 years like
like wow i'm impressed dude like i don't
want that to be me you know what i'm
saying
so uh one of these days you know i'm
just gonna have to make a final decision
to
to my you know my parents have told me
time and time again they would buy me a
plane ticket to home but
i don't know if there's something like
gravitating like keeping me here i don't
know it's like
you're not fed up enough yet yeah i
think that's what it is or
when i was freaking there's something
about this this lifestyle the skid row
lifestyle that's addicting i see a lot
of people
very they can't pull themselves away
from it yeah super comfortable
very comfortable and that's i think
where i'm at i'm very like i'm like
content with it but
at the same time you're getting robbed
and you're you're getting shot and
you're not sleeping at night
it's still comfortable uh
besides all that yeah like
i don't i don't know what what's keeping
me here but it's something
obviously probably drugs honestly yeah
availability of the drugs and because i
have a lot of people back home
that know who i am you know and it's a
lot harder to
get away with you know buying drugs or
you know someone that knows one of my
people that's seen me in a truck house
or something like tell them like
i don't know if it's you're very free
here to do whatever you want right
anything
even the cops will look the other way
i'm white i'm joking
they they they tend to there's some
truth in that not care
about um you know people doing drugs
especially on skid row
you know yeah i mean you just it's
typical you see people smoking crack
doing whatever they want the cops you
know
as they got bigger fish to fry or they
just say you know he's on skid row
well taking him to jail be doing him a
favor you know what i mean [ __ ]
leave this dude alone you know
that's why i see it do you have any you
have any friends
uh i wouldn't call them friends i call
them
acquaintances yes because uh
there's no such things as friends on
skid row
you know you could have a guy play buddy
buddy for you for two days and then
you know he tells you hey man i need to
get some wrestling or crashing your tent
or whatever
then you go to buy a couple single
cigarettes you come back and
everything you know life's gone in a
duffel bag you know that your friend
just took so
no friends for me do you have any issues
with like depression or anxiety or
any of that
[Music]
just like everywhere else there's good
days and bad days out here you see you
seem pretty
stable yeah i like to to take the good
with the bad make the best out of every
situation you know
because i do see people that just sit
out here and cry
all day every time i walk by their tent
i can just expect them to be crying
because
i feel bad for themselves you know i
kind of put myself here
not intentionally but i do
maybe yeah maybe a little intention i
don't know but
yeah i don't i don't try to be uh wimpy
crybaby depressed all the time
might be a little self-destructive oh
yeah
definitely self-destructive
yeah without even thinking about it
i don't even think about it until after
i i've destructed myself then i'm
thinking like
it's just your nature yeah i'm thinking
like i've been like googling it
on my obama phone like if if this can
like rust out or like like get in my
bloodstream or something like this
bullet like
you know they say as long as the initial
bullet hole doesn't kill you the
infection the bullet won't so
you know luckily i i had a big shoulder
blade you know big bone right here to
catch it
you know because i always like trying to
feel my heartbeat and like match it up
like
what it like went through that could
very easily have been your head your
neck or your heart
oh yeah yeah so i stay out of that a
particular area
it's nowhere close to here
a couple train stops up but
you don't see my face up there anymore
and what's the most important lesson
you've learned out here
i'd have to say uh
you don't sell uh drugs on other
people's territories that's the the
the most important one so that's given
the stick to it yeah yeah
oh yeah all right dakota well thank you
so much for sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
getting out of here i appreciate you bro
thank you
you